I made a whole lot of enemies tracksuit mafia
even a black widow that doesn't sound good this
holiday season tell the boss christmas
came early hawkeye is on everyone's list
hi i'm here to kill him clint
barton we need a ton of trick arrows
marvel studios hawkeye only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new marvel hawkeye yelena belova trailer video
for episode 5 next week there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs here a whole bunch of new footage so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
careful for spoilers from hawkeye episode 4 if
you haven't seen it yet you probably saw that
trailer there's a bunch of footage from episode
4 and episode 5 maybe episode 6 the finale too
but it mostly focuses on hawkeye versus yelena
belova in all the different scenes she's wearing
a couple different outfits trying to kill him
in a couple different locations so it sounds
like most of episode five will be hawkeye versus
yelena belova and him trying to talk her down
kate bishop trying to talk her down so that
eventually she learns the truth about natasha's
death because that's the whole premise of her
trying to kill him like obviously this is a
contract she's trying to earn a whole bunch of
money here for killing him but the reason why it's
so personal for her is because she believes that
hawkeye is responsible for her death for those of
you asking why yelena didn't kill kate bishop on
the rooftop at the end of episode four like what
was going on with that head shake when kate pulled
her bow and arrow on her i think this supports the
theory that it was kate's mother who was the one
who hired val and yelena belova to kill hawkeye
technically she would have contacted val who's
like the military contractor in the us government
who runs this thunderbolts team it definitely
seems like it's a thunderbolts team and she just
offered the job to yelena belova because she knew
about the connection with natasha and hawkeye so
it'd be easier to manipulate yelena into killing
him and when kate's mother got on the phone during
that scene in episode four that was probably her
calling yelena to give her more details on the
hawkeye job and she probably told yelena that kate
bishop her daughter was following hawkeye around
like a puppy to make another pizza dog reference
and to not hurt her daughter like we're paying
you a ton of money to kill this avenger mostly
by misleading you but do not hurt my daughter
so yelena was probably nodding at kate as a
way of saying no don't do it don't pull the
bow on me because i don't want to have to hurt
you but if you do attack me i would be forced to
yelena doesn't really care about kate bishop yet
i'll get to that in a second because they are both
dog lovers but if she hurts her she probably won't
get paid on their contract by kate's mother and
she was complaining to val in that black widow
post credit scene that she wasn't getting paid
enough as it was as part of this thunderbolts
team that she's on inval said that this hawkeye
contract would pay her a ton of extra money so
obviously this trailer just confirms yelena belova
isn't just a small cameo scene she's a huge part
of the series in the last few episodes but i think
we can all agree that because the hawkeye series
is supposed to be more comedic and tone like less
dark than something like loki or juan division
they'll have a hopeful ending and hawkeye will
wind up keeping his promise to his family and
make it home in time for actual christmas day
there was three days to go during episode four
so probably two days to go during episode five
and then one day to go during the finale like
by the end of the finale a day will have passed
and he probably makes it home meaning that yelena
belova probably won't wind up killing him i think
it's more a question of how their fights go down
and what actually winds up happening to convince
yelena that black widow's death was not his fault
but just looking through all the trailer footage
and scenes from episode five this looks like it's
going to be amazing and there will be a couple
other big reveals too especially quote unquote
the uncle character they said that we won't have
to wait very long to get answers about that for
everyone that has all these kingpin theories the
scene of hawkeye running through the restaurant in
his tuxedo getting fired at is probably from the
christmas party that kate's mother talked about
for bishop security it just stands to reason that
because bishop security seems like it has so
many ties to the mob and so many shady things
powerful families in new york like during episode
one armand said that her empire was built on lies
so there's probably a bunch of very powerful mafia
people at this party already but it's probably the
tracksuits that are actually firing at him in this
restaurant because they have this huge fight in
rockefeller center on the ice and it seems like he
bails out of one of the windows of this restaurant
and that's when they eventually make it to this
fight a little bit later in the episode where you
actually see kate bishop and him wearing their new
costumes hawkeye's costume is basically the matte
fraction hawkeye costume it also seems like she
gets a big costume upgrade too that's a little bit
closer to her comic book costume the scene of kazi
in someone's house saying tell the boss christmas
came early is either him coming for jack kate's
mother and very small chance that it could be
kingpin but i think it's probably jack or kate's
mother because hawkeye's wife learned the jack
swordsman was listed as the ceo of the shell
company that the tracksuit bros were using so
technically he is their boss but kate's mother is
technically jack's boss because she's the one that
owns bishop's security so technically everyone
is on her payroll but i think that kingpin
is also the true man at the top so kate's mother
is probably using bishop's security to benefit
the kingpin but if we're talking about who is
the villain of the hawkeye series technically i
think that's going to wind up being kate's mother
i think the kingpin stuff is more of like a cameo
scene so you know you could call him the main
villain theoretically but they're treating him
as more like a side character i'll talk about
him in a second when i talk more about ekko and
maya lopez's story going forward for those of
you asking about hawkeye's wife too there's so
many theories now that she is secretly mocking
bird in the mcu so here's my new watch theory i
do like this theory that her name is a little bit
different than what you thought it was so in the
comics during the 1980s for a long time hawkeye
and mockingbird were actually legit married
in the mcu we've only known her as laura barton
but the theory now is that her true full name
is bobbi laura morse barton because we've never
actually known what mockingbird's middle name was
we've only just called her bobbi or barbara morse
but based on everything from episode 4 with her
going full scooby-doo for hawkeye if you didn't
know linda cardellini played velma during the
james gunn scooby-doo movies she just seems like
she had way too many skills for just a casual
mid-western housewife so the theory is she used
to work for nick fury or used to be a shield agent
she is the mockingbird of the mcu and then she
just kind of soft retired kind of like hawkeye
tried to retire so that they could have a family
together in the watch that hawkeye is going after
might be a ladies rolex and it might have belonged
to her when she was an agent and when hawkeye
became ronin like when they got snapped he might
have just taken it with him as a way to remember
her and the reason why it might have been at the
avengers compound during avengers end game is
because hawkeye would have had it with him and he
probably just lost it when thanos blew up the base
but that's just a theory right now i know there's
lots of agents of shield questions like wait
a minute what about the mockingbird on agents
of shield we'll probably learn the truth about
the watch and who hawkeye's wife really is by the
finale so don't worry this is just another yelena
belova scene with her during one of her fights
with hawkeye it kind of looks like they blow up
rockefeller center during this big fight like it's
one of their biggest fight scenes of the actual
series this scene of yelena in the jacket looking
all casual catching the bottle saying hello
looks like it's happening in some kind of
industrial kitchen it might be connected to that
big black tie christmas party in all these other
scenes this looks like the kitchen of a restaurant
the person throwing the bottle at her could be
kate bishop the scene of her in the white black
widow gear from the black widow movie seems like
it's in some totally different rich person's house
it doesn't look like kate's mother's house the
penthouse the architecture the design is totally
different and this person that she's taking down
here seems like a totally new character that we
haven't seen before so maybe this is just some
other random rich person that's connected to
kate's mother somehow her speech when she says
i'm here to kill him clint barton is probably her
talking to kate bishop they do have scenes
together for those of you hoping to see what their
vibe is like like will they bond over their love
of dogs like the pizza dog you have yelena's dog
it's a different breed but still they're both dog
lovers my early theory right now is it actually
won't be hawkeye to be the one to win over yelena
belova it'll actually be kate bishop who convinces
her to chill this is the scene where hawkeye says
we need a ton of trick arrows that's probably set
up for this scene here with him pulling out all
the stark tech trick arrow heads that he said
that he had the new ones that you see him use
here in this big rockefeller center fight scene
seem like an inflatable cushion arrow that he
would normally be using when he jumps off high
buildings to break his fall but he's just using
it in a different way here to get rid of the track
suits this seems like the electro disrupter arrow
from the comics is exactly what it looks like it's
a giant taser field to just disable large groups
of people and him firing three arrows at three
different targets here at the same time is just to
pay off the scene from episode four where he and
kate bishop were talking about their coolest trick
shots they'd ever pulled off like i said there is
supposedly a kingpin cameo scene that people have
been talking about in episode five they could
always wind up having pushed that to the finale
like just save kingpin for a cameo in the finale
but the rumor is is that he will show up in a
small scene at some point during this matt murdock
daredevil is not supposed to show up though the
plan for the echo spin-off series talking more
about what's going on with her according to rumors
marvel plans to bring back most of the netflix
daredevil characters together at the same time
for the echo series and it'll feel kind of like
an unofficial daredevil season four and that'll
help set up a full-blown legit daredevil disney
plus series that they would do around 2023 or
2024 just depending on how soon they get the echo
episodes out but i believe the plan is just based
on all these rumors is that next week when hawkeye
episode 5 airs on wednesday we're supposedly
going to get some small scene with kingpin and
then the day after that the rumor is that we'll
see daredevil show up during spider-man no way
home when that comes out in theaters like bam one
two punch kingpin and daredevil come into the mcu
but if you have any other questions or there's
any other easter eggs that you spotted in these
new trailer scenes just write them below in the
comments and i'll add them to my future videos
my full hawkeye episode 5 video will post
next wednesday just like normal every week my
spider-man no way home review will probably post
monday or tuesday depending on when i get to see
the movie all my post-credits scene videos for the
movie full breakdown easter egg videos will start
posting later next week after the movie comes out
everywhere so make sure and go see it as fast as
possible when you have the chance because it's
going to be awesome everyone click here for my
full hawkeye episode 4 video and click here for my
new spider-man no way home trailer video and eastereggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!